So this next story is just more funny than
anything else because we are obviously not
going to see Donald Trump's tax returns.
But remember how Donald Trump has been saying
since 2015 that if it were up to him, he would
show us his taxes, but they're under audit.
If and when there ever no longer under audit,
he's going to release his tax returns.
Now, that never made sense.
Anybody who could think critically realized
it never made sense, because obviously not
all of his recent tax returns would permanently
be under audit.
And, of course, audits don't last years and
years.
But in any case, it was an excuse.
Trump gave for not showing his taxes.
His personal attorney, Rudy Giuliani.
Maybe it's his former personal attorney at
this point.
I don't know.
He went on Fox News and he said, listen, there's
got to be finality here.
Trump's taxes have been audited and it's been
closed and we're moving on.
You can't.
Now, again, Congress or investigators asked
for Trump's taxes.
He's indirectly saying we need a final point
on this because the whole audit thing has
been closed up.
Well, if the audits are done, let's see the
tax returns.
Right.
Here is Rudy Giuliani himself saying it.
They've been audited and it's fine.
And these are now closed matters as far as
he's concerned, could make the argument that
they have no particularized need for it.
He could also make the argument.
They are not investigating any particularized
crime.
They have no reason to believe that there's
anything wrong with his tax returns.
I mean, all these tax returns have been, by
and large, maybe not the last one, but all
of them have been ordered.
All of them have been either passed on or
settled.
And there should be some finality in your
tax returns.
In other words, we get audited.
We make a deal.
We pay the government.
We don't come after me forever for that.
And also, this is the president tonight.
There are literally 400, 4000 prosecutors
who could now come after his records.
I don't think the court ever thought of that.
All these tax returns have been audited and
there should be finality.
Rudy says, you know, you get audited.
You make a deal and that's it.
He is saying there that the issue of the tax
returns is over because Trump is no longer
under audit and he has moved on.
He's saying you do the audit.
The audit ends and that's it.
You don't keep looking at the same returns
that have been audited.
He's admitting that the audits are done.
If they ever existed.
Now, maybe even more interesting there is
Rudy saying Trump's audits aren't just done,
but they've been settled.
When Rudy says that they've been settled,
it implies, again, you know, talk about self-inflicted
damage.
You settle audits and pay fines when you've
done something wrong on your tax returns.
And Rudy Giuliani there, again, just as an
aside, seems to say not only are the audits
done, but they've been resolved.
Sometimes, you know, you pay a fine and you
move on, which seems to be an admission that
Donald Trump has been deceptive enough on
his tax returns.
You know, you can always claim it was a mistake,
but that he has had to pay fines.
Make good or settle with the IRS when it comes
to his taxes.
It's stunning that this is not getting more
attention.
It's stunning that a lot of people used to
respect Rudy Giuliani.
And again, the reminder is we're not going
to see the tax returns.
Right, to be super clear.
Trump was never going to release the tax returns.
The Supreme Court's decision isn't going to
get them released before the election.
And the important thing for us is we don't
need to see them to know how to vote in November.
It's not like we're saying, you know, I on
one hand, I don't like these things Trump
has done.
And on the other hand, this wasn't so bad.
But if I could only see the tax returns, I'd
be able to decide what to do in November.
Take solace in that, even though we're not
going to see Trump's tax returns.
We don't really need to.
We already know what we should be doing in
November when it comes to Trump versus Biden.
And I think that's the if you're looking for
any positive takeaway from any of this, it's
we've got enough information to know how to
vote in November without seeing Donald Trump's
tax returns tonight.
Join me at 8:00 p.m. Eastern on YouTube and
Twitch and Facebook for the third ever David
Pakman show chess tournament.
I'll be playing and streaming.
Anybody can play community event.
No cost to play, no barrier to entry.
It's completely free.
Just register at David Pakman dot com slash
chest's.
That's tonight to Tuesday, July 14th, 8:00
p.m. Eastern.
I will see you then.
And of course, remember that you can get the
daily audio podcast every single day right
around three p.m. Eastern on whatever is your
favorite podcasting app, Spotify I tunes,
Google Play podcast pod being, if you will,
anyway, wherever you want to hear it.
You can hear it.